if it's not Instagram official isn't
even really official palsy and Evan
Peters have taken their romance one step
further by going public on social media
we have to start at the very beginning
over the weekend the singer posted
photos from her almost famous Halloween
party on Friday where she dressed up as
Marilyn Manson and Evan rocked a Juggalo
costume paying tribute to the insane
clown posse that same night they were
spotted leading the event together and
Halsey was even wearing his Jersey then
on Saturday the couple was spotted again
this time making a joint appearance at
the American Horror Story 100th episode
party were they dazzled in a couples
costume as Sonny and Cher it's been less
than a month since the dating rumors
between Halsey and Evan began
circulating I don't read things on the
Internet
I keep away from reading comments on the
Internet it's just full of negativity
there and I remember myself that you
know I'm doing well and the people I
love are happy and taken care of and
everything is good cause he was
previously linked to rapper G easy they
split in 2018 after a year of dating I'm
really fortunate to be surrounded by a
lot of like talented musicians and
actors and personalities and a lot of
people who are really young like me and
mostly everyone just tells me surround
yourself with your friends good people
and don't take yourself too seriously
you know if something bad happens it's
not the end of the world and you always
have time to prove yourself as for Evan
he was engaged to actress Emma Roberts
but the two officially called it quits
in March as an actress well you know
what does she mean to you on-screen
working opposite her creatively I don't
know it's a hard one to answer I think
ultimately for me and her I think it's
just that we're together all the time
and we're best friends so I think that
like everything just becomes that much
easier and all the stuff that sort of
can upset you or annoy you or frustrate
you and we kind of look at each other
and then just kind of laugh about it and
get through it so so yeah I just think
it's really fun working with her I have
a great time working with her et spoke
with Halsey last year where she candidly
explained her songwriting process and
how she's choosing to focus on happiness
over heartbreak it's my first time
writing music about being happy which is
really cool cuz I think a lot of the
time as an artist you write about you
know they
that you have angst or confusion or
anxiety about and it's important to do
that to need to purge your you know it's
like therapeutic in just the same way we
only tell our friends about things about
our partners when they kind of write
songs about them too so I'm trying to
really push myself into trying to put
into words just how happy I am
[Music]